je me déclare comme sur celle libéral
mais je trouve que les statuts doivent
rester basse il est belge accepte d'être
associé à une personne qui qui a fait du
mal un peu parce que hier il a quand
même tué des millions de personnes c'est
leur problème mais doivent aussi
accepter que dans le pays où ils sont il
n'y a pas que des belges et des
personnes de toutes les nationalités qui
ne veulent pas voir leurs agresseurs si
je peux dire ça comme ça dans les dents
levin enfin les voir tous les jours
comme ça en statut voilà je suis à
moitié d'origine congolaise est donc ça
veut dire lié aux deux côtés de
l'histoire c'est à dire celle belges et
congolaises et pour moi j'avais déjà
signé une pétition qui commence à
tourner sur le retrait de la statue du
trône
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu c'est une
structure qui beaucoup plus
impressionnante que celle qui a été
retiré à anvers
parce que on montre léopold ii
triomphant donc sur un cheval à deux pas
du quartier congolais et même africain
de bruxelles à savoir combien ça
dérangeait pas c'est la pire il faut que
ça reste époques et les enfants ils
sachent
ou quand on oublie pas son ancien nom
mais pas son ombre c'est ce qu'on est